so up next uh is our flash mobs uh
segment this is a series of short
presentations by some of the people that
are bringing us the next iterations of
the internet um
first we have yancy strickler
so a floating swimming pool in the
hudson river
a series of interchangeable lenses that
attach to your iphone camera
a video camera built into a set of
sunglasses that can record everything
that you see in real time these products
don't exist yet but they will soon
thanks to kickstarter kickstarter is a
website that allows artists and
designers to fund projects
by going directly to the public
so far 700 let me make sure i have this
right uh more than 700 000 people have
contributed more than 70 million dollars
to artist projects on kickstarter and a
hundred more are posted every day
uh kickstarter has introduced a radical
and radically successful new model for
innovation and here to talk about it is
one of the co-founders yancey strickler
uh hi everybody thanks for having me my
name is yancy and i'm one of the
founders of kickstarter um as jason was
just explaining kickstarter is a funding
platform for creative projects so it's a
way for musicians filmmakers artists
photographers designers technologists to
make the things that they want and they
do it by reaching out directly to their
audience into the internet to raise the
funds that they need but both those
words creative and products are
important to us we don't allow
fundraising for charities or causes and
everything must be a project a precisely
defined thing with a beginning and an
end so we don't allow any sort of
open-ended fundraising on the site
this is a kickstarter project page and
one of the tricks about kickstarter is
that all the funding is all or nothing
so when you start a project you say how
much money you need to do it and you
give yourself an amount of time to raise
those funds so typically about 30 days
if you raise or if you raise your goal
or exceed it by the time of your
deadline all the credit cards are
charged and you get your cash and you do
your thing if you come short then you
don't get anything at all so this
product right here which is to put on a
24 hour cycle of waiting for godot
because he has 10 hours left to raise
575 dollars so if no one else pledged
this project it would not happen in this
case it did and projects always do when
they get to this moment
so we've been around for about two years
and during that time the site has had
some success we've had over 9 000
projects successfully funded over 700
000 people have supported a project and
collectively they've contributed it's
now over 70 million dollars and right
now it's over 2 million dollars a week
that's being pledged to projects on the
site
in terms of how we make our money if a
product is successfully funded we take
five percent of the total amount raised
as our fee
one interesting thing about kickstarter
is that the moment at which your project
is almost certain to succeed the point
at which you're going to make it is
actually when you raise just 30 percent
of your funding goal so projects that
raise 30 of their goal eventually make
it over 90 percent of the time so it's
really about getting that core audience
you have people who really buy into what
you're doing and if they do they will
buy into your story and they'll tell it
and they'll share it around the west the
rest of the web so that threshold to
reach is pretty low and you see that
also in how the money is distributed so
even though 44 percent of products
succeed over 85 percent of the funds go
to projects that do make it so it's
really feast or famine there's either
support for your idea or there's not
support for your idea and we think that
this statistic really shows uh how
effective the all or nothing idea is
um so why is it that kickstarter works
what is it about these projects or this
platform it's allowing people to have
this kind of success and there are a lot
of reasons that you could cite but the
one that i like most of all is that
every project is a story
each project is a story of a real person
doing something important to them
something of note something that they
really care about and we get a chance to
not only follow along and watch what
happens but to participate in all sorts
of meaningful ways and these stories are
told through a couple different ways
the biggest is video we're primarily a
video driven site eighty percent of
products launch of the video and videos
are basically commercials made made by
normal people it's a minute and a half
two minutes three minutes of someone's
saying this is what i want to do here's
how i'm going to do it here's why i
should be a part of it but people are
uncomfortable pitching themselves they
include all the false takes the weird
mistakes they made they want to show
that we're just like us they want to
show that they are the audience member
that there's not a line in between
and to give you a sense of how these
work i'm going to show you a little
montage that's sort of the typical
kickstarter video
hello hi hi there hello kickstarters hey
i thought we were gonna do hello hi i
love your new shoes are those new shoes
hi my name is raquel and i'm totally
naked yeah
and i could go on but this is a
kickstarter campaign video and i haven't
even told you what my project is yet
i would like to help my dad publish a
children's story we get together and we
do a podcast
stop motion animations let people
actually be able to buy a couture dress
that they themselves design this time i
decided to write things that were more
lyrical i made a film called
co-dependent lesbian space alien seek
sane right now i'm sitting on over 200
hours of incredible footage i'd like
your help to complete
it does not work without you we need you
to be a part of this this is a
collaborative experience your support of
course will not go unrewarded we've got
cd posters t-shirts i think together
we can literally be the next great
frontier in space and earth exploration
let's go make a story i'm really excited
for this i think that this is worth
doing we can make it together thanks for
watching our
kickstarter video
this project is really important to me
and any support is greatly appreciated
and so you see a lot of faces you see
just people that's what this is it's
real people talking to you about what it
is that they care most about
and the other way these stories get told
are through rewards
um
we're gonna go back to slide sorry our
reward so it's it's not a donation
platform i don't just give you ten
dollars and get nothing i give you ten
dollars and i get ten dollars of
something in exchange and it's up to
each project creator to sculpt what that
is the one thing that's not allowed is
any sort of financial return or equity
that's strictly forbidden but most
commonly you see if i'm writing a book
you get a copy of the book maybe i name
a character after you maybe get invited
to the set or you get a walk-on roll or
you get to do the hand claps on track
three whatever people want to offer it's
completely up to them
this picture here this polaroid that you
see in the background this is the best
reward i've gotten from any kickstarter
project there was very early on we had
an art project by a woman named emily
richmond part of it was to sail around
the world and she said for 15 at some
point on her trip she would take a
polaroid picture and she would mail it
to you for wherever she was next time
she got into port and about two months
ago i got a weird envelope in the mail
that was beat to [ __ ] had these weird
stamps on it and open it up and i find
that inside and it's folded up inside of
a map and written on one side of the map
is a letter describing exactly where
she's sitting on this island in the
pacific on the other side she had
circled the island on the map itself and
i got this for 15
and i'm a part of emily's story and this
is something that has deep meaning to me
you know it's romantic it's amazing this
will stay in my dresser mirror for the
rest of my life and i'm a stranger on
the internet who gave her 15
this is really what's happening on a
large scale so i want to walk you
through the two biggest projects we've
had so far and they really give a good
sense of sort of the yin and yang of how
the site works and the first is called
blue like jazz and blue like jazz is a
new york times bestselling book about
five or six years ago and the author of
the book donald miller had been working
for years to adapt it into a film they
had raised money they had a cast
everything was set and then september
16th of last year they lost their
funding the traditional money came in
and said no we don't like this we don't
think this is going to work and the
whole thing got cancelled so two fans of
the book saw this blog post and thought
we want to change that so they reached
out to the reached out to donald miller
and the the filmmaker and they said how
much would it take to get the production
restarted and they said 125 thousand
dollars the guy said cool they started a
kickstarter project to try to do it and
five weeks later the project finished
raising three hundred and fifty thousand
dollars restarted production the film
would be in theaters this fall and so
why do people become a part of this way
there's a story that they're now a huge
part of this movie is their movie
whenever this comes out in theaters they
get to claim some moral ownership over
this they get bragging rights but also
they get things everyone who backed the
project gets a personal phone call from
the director saying thank you that's
4495 phone calls which he is still
making
for a hundred dollars you got to be an
associate producer on the film 799
people did that for ten thousand dollars
the writer the author of the book will
come to your house and do a screening
personally with you about ten people did
that so people had this chance to really
become a part of this something that
they really loved in a very meaningful
way
but also kickstarter has started to be
used for pre-orders and product design
and things that aren't quite as artistic
or have a different kind of story behind
them and a great case is something
called the tick tock the tick tock was
designed by a guy named scott wilson and
it's a wristband that turns an ipod nano
into a watch and he's an established guy
he's made things in the past and so he
took this around to the ipod accessory
companies see if anyone wanted to put
money into it and no one liked it they
said you know there's not going to be an
audience for this it's too expensive
it's just not going to happen so we put
up a kickstarter project to try to raise
fifteen thousand dollars to manufacture
a few hundred because that's when it
became feasible to go through the
process fast forward four weeks later
and he'd raised nine hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and sold pre-orders for
fourteen thousand of these and it went
on stale in the in the apple store a few
weeks ago and so here what happened was
he gave people a chance to have a
greater ownership of the story and a
greater connection to it those 13 512
people you know they're just waiting for
someone to ask what that thing is when
they're wearing because they get to tell
the story about how this happened and
for scott he gets to have this perfect
product he made it in a way that imbued
a story directly into the thing itself
and allows it you know just exist in the
world i mean this is this is a piece of
plastic and rubber that has an author in
a way that we don't normally think of it
and has that story just intrinsic to its
very nature
but of course not every project makes it
and the reason why projects fail are
reasons that honestly we feel
comfortable with they're people who just
haven't done a lot of work in the past
they're this is like their first attempt
to do something generally what happens
with these products these are people who
have done good work who know how to tell
a good story and they're cashing in on
that gravitas they're saying to their
audience hey we've done these things
before here's here's my next thing so
the projects that fail kind of should
fail not that they're bad ideas but
maybe they haven't done that leg work
they need to get there
so
kickstarter itself we have an
interesting story we're not a typical
startup by any means
my co-founder and our ceo perry chen
first had the idea 10 years ago he was
living in new orleans and he was trying
to put on a concert and he didn't have
the money to do it and he thought if
only i knew beforehand how many people
wanted to go to this thing i could
create a threshold if enough people
wanted to go it happened if it wouldn't
it wouldn't happen
so he had that idea and about four or
five years later in brooklyn he and i
met at a restaurant uh called diner this
restaurant here where i was a regular
and he was my waiter and perry was
waiting tables i was working as a music
journalist at the time
one day over brunch we were shooting the
[ __ ] and he he just mentioned this idea
and so we started to work on it together
uh it took us a while neither of us are
technical you know a waiter and a rock
critic or not the ideal founding team
but somehow we managed to make it work
and we thought a lot about the fact that
most ideas are just ideas you know
they're not trying to produce revenue
they're not trying to make people rich
you just want that thing in your head to
exist in the real world and you want to
feel proud of that that those kinds of
ideas had no home in the world that we
wanted to create a place that was
different that supported that kind of
thing and that's kind of what we've done
this is our office here in the lower
east side we're right up right above the
bar there
this is our front door
which i kind of enjoy
we get a lot of confused people coming
to see us
you could try to find our buzzer there
i'll give you a dollar if you can but
you know this is just this is the world
that we come from and this this is how
we approach this we just think about how
can we help more art and culture exist
in the world and and you know how is it
that we can help people do the things
that they love
so at this point um packed into this
small tournament building we're we're 25
people um you could see the whole team
here this is uh our team page we have
little animated gifts of everyone just
laughing
but this kind of describes who we are
we're half and half people who work on
the technology who work directly with
artists to help them make their dreams
come true um so thank you so much for
your time and for listening and uh it's
great to be here
i love that story um that was amazing uh
so here's a scenario you've moved
you've just moved into a new house or
apartment and you've been unpacking
boxes all day and you're sweaty and
exhausted and it's three in the morning
and you realize you just want to take a
shower and go to bed and you realize
that you don't have any shower rings
so what do you do you've got a few
options um this is new york so you could
probably find a 24-hour hardware store
um you could take a bath which sounds
terrible um or you could fire up your
makerbot and print some shower rings
immediately
makerbot is the world's first affordable
3d printer
it has been used to make everything from
puzzles to gears to a bust of stephen
colbert's head
and our next speaker bree pettis is the
founder of makerbot he's going to talk
about how it's revolutionizing design
and manufacturing so bree
come on
cool good to be here uh i'm not gonna
talk about social networks
i'm gonna talk about things and i'm
pretty excited about this because
things are something we don't really
think about in technology anymore we
think about like you know a lot of we've
talked about the cloud we've been
talking about you know social networks
not community mind you but social
networks and
um
let's
so i'm going to talk to you about robots
and that makes things gears gangstas
rabbits and clocks
and just a quick question how many of
you in your business have have a portion
of it where you share something an open
source part of it
okay those without your hands up
consider your business over in five
years
so this is a makerbot it's open source
you can download all every design file
if you're a user you know exactly how it
works you can improve it you can modify
it and release the your improvements and
everybody benefits
and
i've got a little video here where
basically you know i'm going to skip
that because you can go ahead and see it
right over here because we're printing
out stuff all day
and
basically the way we work is we want to
give everything away in terms of uh the
way that it works and how it works the
design files schematic files all that
kind of stuff
a lot of people freak out when they hear
this and they're like you don't have
anything that you keep and hide secret
and all this kind of stuff and we're
like no and we like it that way it's
better
and it's
i could go on and on about open source
and
uh instead i'm going to talk about um
what do you do when you have a machine
that can make you anything what when you
have the potential to like just
manufacture things on your desktop and
usually because we're so used to buying
things
when we find out we can make anything
right now we think wait what
and so
you can make some really crazy and
wonderful things here's a snake
here's a little heart box that you could
put a present in for your sweetie
here's a whistle maybe you need to go
referee a game it prints that little
ball inside as well
an octopus it's like a barrel of monkeys
but with more
legs
and you can push the envelope of what's
possible we've got users who are making
uh
cathedral playsets where there's a you
can put it all together and have a
cathedral in any way you want
and here's a
this is designed uh
to be like this big so like too big to
turn around in your bathtub and it's
made in components because so even
though the machine can only make things
about five by five by five inches you
can do
whole sections and then smush them all
together to do all to do bigger things
so okay so
you can make anything but what if you
can take anything and then mush it
together with anything else you get
digital mashups which
i mean it goes from the interesting and
the weird and the wacky to the downright
bizarre so you've got a dragon head
and then you've got a bunny and you put
them together
and you get a drabbit
which those of you know
especially the british in the audience
is deadly
don't throw hand grenades at them
so this just works you take something
you take something else you smush it
together you upload it to our site
thingiverse which is our place where
people share digital designs and then
other people can download them and
improve them and do wonderful things
with them publish them under an open
license like a creative commons or uh
gpl license and then you win
and then
you know as with anything that you put
on the internet
the unexpected things happen
so our whole mission is to create
infrastructure for creative people to do
wonderful things and part of that is
this culture of sharing and as
we're not used to a culture of sharing i
mean we grow up and in kindergarten
we're like okay
uh
we learn to share toys but then we
go to school and get a job and we're
like no this is mine there's a line
there's a fence you can't go over it but
it turns out when you share things just
like you were learned when you were a
kid you really often get more back when
you share things and one of the
wonderful things about the internet is
it lets you do attribution really well
so when we set up thingiverse we made it
so that when wyzorg
uploaded a gangsta
you can go and if somebody thinks this
is cool
they can
well first of all he's published it
under the cc by sharelike license which
means
you can absolutely copy this as much as
you want and you can actually modify it
as long as you release it under the same
license
so you go ahead and you press i made one
which is something you can press on
there and it says did you make just a
copy if so just upload a picture and
that'll show the original designer like
how cool it is that you made your own
copy of it did you modify the design and
improve it or change it or make it worse
go and upload the actual file and it'll
automatically give attribution to wise
org so that he knows that he modified
his thing and he gets credit for kind of
like
having the first gangsta and in fact
that becomes important
when this first went up we were like
okay that's cool he printed it out it's
a little like kind of gangsta figure
it's kind of got he's got bad posture
and a hoodie and then you take the snake
that we saw earlier and you put them
together and instead of having a gangsta
you've got a snakester
and then you can take that gangsta and
de-res it so it's like it's just going
through a bad version of tron or
something like that
and
i'm clicking fast here
devil stuff put the devil on his head
and you've got a devil gangster
you've got a talisman which hangs around
your neck
stylist uh
buddhis boodsta
you've got boots that the legend
continues which is the stylist and the
booster which is a mashup on top of a
mashup
take the rabbit
you've got rabbits to
take the rabbits take the gangsta and
put it on top of the rabbit and you've
got the bunny star the again stank
yes
uh then you've got more decimated
bunnies people love this bunny it's a
very classic model you can put optimus
prime's head on it
it's party
put his head on the gangster you got
prime stuff
it it really is not stopping like i've
had to
keep like in making this project in this
presentation i had to keep updating it
this is one of those things that you
push down and it folds over but it's a
gangster instead of like a pony we all
know han solo is incom
in carbonite
but now you can get a lego man in
carbonite
and of course the carbonite stuff
and then if you take this the gangster
and you cut them in half and you put the
bottom half on top of the bottom half
you get the stostoff
take walt disney's head which somebody
made a model of and published under a
creative commons license
and add an actual brain which is from a
medical model and put it in walt
disney's head
and you have
well something that shouldn't exist in
real life and then you can put it on a
gangster
and then you can make a gangsta pee
and then of course it just keeps going
to the next level somebody uploads a
urinal and then
people yeah this is you know when it
gets to the point where people are
peeing you know it's a meme right
so
uh two designers had a battle one wanted
one had something that the other wanted
and
the one wanted to pay for it and the
other one wanted to give it to him and
so they made a deal okay we have one
hour and you have to do a derivative of
the gangsta and whichever one gets more
likes at the end of day
wins and so the first one uploaded a
pesta which is a pez topper like
actually like you print it out on a
makerbot and you stick it on a pez top
and you dispense candy
with
a stetson and a bow tie
cool
and
the other one made chesta and he totally
won
so he got to his his winning what meant
he got to send the thing for free
without having the other guy pay for it
which so it's gentleman's argument
uh
scanned colbert of course there was
colbertsta
and it just went on and on this is a
this is a few days ago and there's
already been like another 10 derivatives
of colbert's head
including the statue of colberty and
just horrible ideas that when you have
them you realize that you have to make
them real and then you print them out
so
right now we've got this community of
people that are doing wonderful things
and um
and it's going to be easier when you
have a community of people who are doing
things it's important to give them
ways to connect ways to work together
ways to actually like
have infrastructure for creativity if
your users aren't talking to each other
try and make that happen it's one of the
most wonderful things that you can do
and there will be more things to mash up
i'm just going to move right through
this so there's mesh mixture to do this
this is actually just came out for the
mac as well so you just it makes it
really easy to take two models and just
smush them together
it's like
it's easy it's like kind of iphoto easy
and it's weird
openscad is for programmers in the
audience if you're a programmer
this is a program that makes it really
easy for you to match up things and
actually do amazing parametric designs
and
part of this again is about a culture of
sharing all these
openscad and pavre and these kind of
things are open source projects where
people have said oh i wanted to do this
and so they take the code base they add
to it they improve it and then they
re-release it and it's better
all these kind of this kind of openness
gives people permission to play if
people aren't taking apart the products
that you're making in some way and
making them better they're not
improving your product and they could be
um
just going to skip right through these
i've got these gears over here
this guy made this guy made that last
gear which is like a heart that's all
gear and
um
he was he did clearly like says like i
took this guy's gear script i took i
took this i had seen this guy's broken
heart but i wanted it to be different so
you could twist it differently and he's
giving attribution it's something that
people do in this culture of sharing
where they say if there's something cool
let's let's really give people
attribution so that they know that since
we're building on top of them they get
the credit for it and then it's kind of
like you stand on the shoulder of giants
so if you stand on my shoulders and
somebody else stands on your shoulders
eventually i can stand back on
somebody's shoulders who's stopping on
my shoulders and it's like a standing on
shoulders mobius strip
so there's the original one and then it
just goes on as you know like when these
things the derivatives happen we've got
a sphere we've got a cube that twists
and gets all deformed of course the
weighted storage cube these things have
to happen
uh and then
i'm gonna talk about just the clocks for
a minute and this is an amazing story
and basically this guy wanted to make a
clock that he could make her bot and he
just decided okay i'm just going to try
this out i'm going to make a little
simple model and it won't work i know it
but he uploaded it anyway as a bro as a
machine as a model that didn't work and
people printed it out and tried it out
and gave him feedback
and this happened a lot he did a lot of
different
iterations on this and a whole community
came together they ended up getting
their own google group and stuff like
this to basically work on making a
printable clock and it's the point now
where all the different parts work
separately the escapement which goes
back and forth and then all the gears
which now do minute
hour and second hands which is cool and
they all look really cool and
it also helps when people get together
getting your users together again i
mentioned that it's just cool they
they're happy when they're they're
working on things and they actually get
to be together
up
so
this is the end i'm going to go back a
step here
um so the big ideas here like you're
basically share
just share not many not enough of you
had your hands up with your business as
a sharing entity
if you're not doing it the the internet
will kill you
uh
encourage the edge cases
and encourage people to do off what's
called like off-brand uses of your your
technology and when they do find ways of
incorporating that in and adding it to
what you do embrace that rather than
than do that microsoft learned that with
a connect recently that's been a very
powerful lesson for them
let them connect i keep saying that over
and again
over and over again and and make things
happen and
we're just at the beginning of this time
of sharing and so you know even though
i'm saying if you're not doing this
you're gonna die it's the perfect time
to start exploring these kind of options
and
i hope you do and wonderful things will
happen
thank you
that's great
thanks man
so uh when you work at wired magazine
you come across people like steve
perlman every once in a while um there
aren't that many of them out there but
we tend to write about them and they're
people that frankly kind of piss me off
a little bit because
you know steve perlman didn't have to
invent onlive he
had already created web tv he was one of
the founders of one of the guys who
worked at apple on quicktime he'd
already revolutionized several
industries and destroyed several more
but you know what the hell why not
create a cloud-based streaming video
game service why not
um
now he's apparently
going to announce some new
development that's going to destroy
several more industries so
he's done it before i'm sure he'll do it
again let's bring him out steve pullman
all right that's all thanks very much
all right
so i get the privilege of doing a live
demo with lots of tricky technology much
of it which is brand new so while
they're setting up there
first of all i don't know if uh any of
you have already heard of on live has
anyone heard of that service
all right a few hands i like that so
it's a video game service that we've
developed that
allows us to run video games from the
cloud rather than having any
computational power locally and of
course games are very performance
demanding we have all of them running in
data centers and the data centers can be
about a thousand miles away so certainly
for gamers there's lots of reasons why
that's great and i've got the first
couple of slides once they get the slide
deck going talk about that um but the
the thing about video games is they're
so performance demanding with
instantaneous response with high
performance graphics with you know
suddenly changing scenes that in order
to make that work with the video going
through the internet over any kind of
connection even a wireless connection at
a network show like this
where you know there's obviously a lot
of people going sharing the connection
when you're tweeting or whatever you're
doing
and so
to make that work so we're there yep all
right good
so i think we can go move this on to the
other screen right
all right good so we got the other
screen up
uh
i see you're duplicating the screen let
me go and just do a real quick screen
resolution thing here
uh okay
all right um
second here
there we go hooray
good okay
there we are on live okay it's a company
that we um took about nine years to
develop we have some big investors lots
of people lots of ip
okay we talked about this uh instantly
video games you don't have to have
a particular console xbox or playstation
3 or high end pc
with on live all you need to do is go to
onlive.com you got a pc mac could be a
netbook uh or a any uh tv set we have
tvs gonna have online built in or we
have a little thing called the micro
console hooks up to a tv and then any
mobile device it can be an uh you know
an ipad or android or etc
the way it works is we have
video games hosted in a data center on
the right there and then on the left
side you have your little device if you
hit a button on that device the action
goes up through the internet through
whatever connection you got it figure
out the next frame of the video game and
then streams it down so fast that that
round trip seems instantaneous
perceptually it seems like the game is
running locally it's pretty cool and
it's really worth giving it a try if you
haven't tried it before
so what we're announcing today we just
did this big announcement with juniper
and
it's one of those big announcements that
only i think some people understand just
how big the implications are
and what we've done is we've created a
no compromise virtual desktop does
anyone here ever use something like
citrix
any hands
oh my god almost all the hands okay is
anyone here like citrus citrix
okay you're gonna love this demo does
anyone have any stock in citrix
all right you're not gonna like this
demo all right so we've created a
virtual desktop it's kind of like where
citric is talking about for doing for
cloud thing it's nice i can point to
something that that exists
except the remote desktop feels local in
fact a lot of ways it's better than
local even everything with media video
and flash it works instantaneously it's
compatible with all devices pc macs
tablets phones monitors even tv sets if
you get a presentation in a boardroom or
something
and the cloud-based apps can have
unprecedented performance sure we could
do office apps like outlook or or you
know powerpoint etc but we could do
really high-end apps it's scalable
maintainable and particularly because
this relationship that we have with
juniper it's secure and you see the
diagram looks just like the video game
diagram we could run some like office we
can run autodesk apps in the data center
and then when you hit a button on your
keyboard mouse or whatever goes up
through the internet and then comes back
down but using video game class low
latency low latency video so the screen
updates so fast the desktop on any of
these devices feels like it's running
locally sounds unlikely well
here you could see a video window
that i'm playing
and the thing i'm going to show you now
is that in fact
what we've been doing all this time is
actually running through the cloud i'm
running a powerpoint here
and powerpoint is in fact
running in our data center
3000 miles away oops and i actually went
on to the next slide but powerpoint is
running in our data center 3000 miles
away
and i'm controlling it from here so i
have the full capability of powerpoint
and if you don't believe that
then let me go and show you that
i have a windows desktop running here
on this ipad
separately entirely and i can go and
transfer powerpoint over it
then over on the samsung galaxy tab
android tablet
i'll do even better than that this is
the on live service and if you go into
what we call the arena normally we could
do is watch people playing well actually
i can go and watch
this session of powerpoint no problem
and if you see there i'll start playing
and there it is
so pretty cool all right and in fact if
i go and step out for a moment
from powerpoint
if i just minimize the window you see i
am on a windows desktop and if i go in
here to um this uh internet explorer
here's our online website let me go to
speedtest.net
just to give you
context where we are
all right so speedtest.net is loading
and again where does it think we are
take a look at this okay it thinks that
we are
here
oops it thinks that we are here uh way
over in california because that's where
our data center is
let's see what our speed is this
laptop's running on wi-fi
10 millisecond ping to california
over 250 megabits a second
actually we're not 250 megabits a second
what we've done is we've pinned
speedtext.next it's running off of a
video game data center with 10 gigabits
links going through our juniper switches
okay so you've got 10 gigabit per second
browsing running in this all right
and
so it's kind of cool and uh
so let me go and go back to on live
again to prove once again that
that whole outlook thing i was showing
you is really virtually running
very far away and here i am in the
online service running
and now what i can go do is go in the
arena here and now i can go watch stuff
here so i've got a couple of things here
in fact i'm going to go and watch this
which is this
ipad desktop and i'm going to run
powerpoint here
there comes up
in fact what i'm going to do is load
that very same presentation
open
powerpoint presentations and there it is
all right so i can go there and i can go
and uh find the slide that i was just on
media rich
and uh then i'll go and click there
and again for those of you who've used
citrix you've never seen anything like
this before i can go jump ahead anything
full flexibility with any level of video
i'm running on an ipad over wi-fi with
all of you folks going and perhaps
jamming up the video channel here okay
so
it's being hosted 3 000 miles away all
right so the other thing i want to show
you which is kind of fun is like if
you're so first of all you have all the
you know pinch and zoom stuff okay so if
i wanted to go here and
you know edit something here i can go
bring up this thing here and i can
instead of saying meteor rich i can say
you know media you know awesome
rich okay
and uh you know edit back there so again
you have
the capability now
once again of having everything you'd
normally do in powerpoint but you're
running on an ipad or whatever device
then i could do even something cooler
like you know
hello
i figured it out all right so we have we
have completely embraced the ipad
but we've carried over with a windows
desktop and i'm running this whole damn
thing 3000 miles away it's just awesome
anyways and you get all the games too
which is really cool of course you would
never do that while you're at the office
i'm quite sure but anyways so the other
thing we bring to the ipad is wait a
minute we've got a browser here and we
can go do that really cool thing with
speedtest.net and i'm going to do that
again speedtest.net now running on an
ipad but wait a minute speedtest.net
doesn't run on ipad gets a flash app
but i'm going to run an ipad now and now
i'm going to go pin speedtest.net with a
10 millisecond pin
a 10 millisecond ping okay so that's
cool and then i'm going to take you to
this mercedes-benz site which is this
ridiculously complex a site
for flash and look how fast it's loading
again i mean if you try this at home on
a six megabit connection so it'll take a
minute or two
and i've got flash running no worries
the whole thing runs perfectly smoothly
on an ipad okay
so and here i am remember i am
spectating this amongst many other
things so let me show you one other
thing i'm expecting if you could bring
up the um
oh this this other galaxy tab here in
the interest of time i pre-loaded this
and
here i'm running something called
autodesk maya which is one of the most
advanced applications in the world to
show what automatic maya can do i'm
going to quickly go and show in our
showcase here
this demo here
and this shows the kind of 3d graphics
3d characters that we create when you
have unlimited computing performance
and i guess you can't hear the audio
there she's saying hi i'm jennifer
welcome to on live okay so let's go back
now to spectating let's show you what
what the quality is and then i'm going
to go here
and then this is the tool that created
it now this is not a tool that can run
on on an android tablet or an ipad it's
not a tool it can run on a laptop but it
runs just fine here
and in fact of course i get the full
flexibility that you would normally have
just about done here and the full
flexibility i can zoom right into the
pores in her skin
and i can go and rotate her etc
so you're looking at the highest of high
performance apps this is it it's as high
as it gets running on any device
wherever you are in the world so
to wrap up what we've done is we've
completely virtualized computing this is
cloud in the most general sense of the
world okay and you can see with the
discipline of getting video games to run
at super high performance made it
absolutely uh easy to knock out uh you
know application level performance
that's needed and make it run so
beautifully on all these different
devices very excited to be working with
citrix and have the announcement today
with them and it's the citrix switches
oh man did i say that oh man okay
sorry
very sorry very happy sorry about that
very happy working with uh um
with juniper
we have all of our data our data center
is all driven for switches and that's
why we're able to do such low latency
stuff thanks very much
you